a typical italian olive farm struggling
in a period of atypical weather
unpredictable and extreme weather is
becoming more common making it
increasingly difficult for farmers like
mario cascone
in 2018 an exceptionally late frost left
him with little choice
the farm lost 40 percent of its trees
that day many others required drastic
action
this is a clear example of the direct
effects of climate change that little
tree we see there was the same size as
the big tree next to it before we had to
cut it back because it was completely
frozen it'd be as big as the other tree
if that hadn't happened
newly regrown trees give mario hope
still earnings are down because they
produce less oil
olives are one of italy's most iconic
staples the fact that they're under
threat has shown italians that climate
change has arrived in full force here
as have repeated floods in places like
venice record heat waves raging
wildfires and extended periods of
drought
surrounded by warming seas and at
growing risk of desertification italy
now finds itself on the front lines of
climate change
heavily reliant on agriculture italy is
hoping to take the lead in adapting to a
changing climate
the government has launched a new
ministry for ecological transition and
earmarked 80 billion dollars of eu
coveted recovery funds to come up with
solutions to live in a warming world
environmental transition has significant
costs and it is essential that
governments make direct commitments to
help their citizens and businesses
handle them italy has partnered with the
uk to host this year's u.n climate
summit cop 26 coming up in november in
scotland
and this week milan is hosting two
events ahead of those meetings the youth
for climate conference and the final
ministerial meetings before cop 26.
at 30 years old casconi could pick a
different career but he is drawn to the
challenge ahead
we need to be creative and open to
adaptation it's not easy it's hard work
but at the same time it can be
fulfilling
on the front lines the desire to solve
the problem is there but will world
leaders take the tough decisions to make
that possible adam rainey al jazeera
caneto italy